this is the new nine-millimeter now it's
on hot if we can set it up so you can't
unlock your phone unless you got the
right fingerprint why can't we do the
same thing for our guns in a sense it's
working the same way that my iphone does
very similar we mechanically unlock the
gun and its rate of fire
I wear this then I'm the only one that
can operate this guy oh yeah there's a
chip inside the ring that's a pretty
scary thought that one you would want to
use law enforcement as a marketing tool
these aren't people that you kind of
want to use as a guinea pig
we have 21,000 firearms suicide 800
children who die from firearms every
year don't common with you right now
we're in a dorm here at MIT and on our
way to meet CAI who has designed his own
smart gun hey Christophe
let's meet you congrats on yeah I treat
you to come on in nah totally excited
the dorm room in there yeah exactly
eventually we won't be working on Glocks
we'll be making our own custom gun but
for right now we're just modifying
normal firearms and basically the way
this works is this little thing inset
into the grip here I've actually got one
is a fingerprint sensor so that's the
same thing that's right there just here
and this fingerprint sensor basically
goes under your middle finger when you
pick up a firearm so your hand sort of
would curl around it like this and
naturally that middle finger would land
right on the sensor here so in a sense
it's working the same way that my iPhone
does it's very very similar to an iPhone
we mechanically unlock the gun and it's
ready to fire Americans love their guns
with roughly 300 million in the US
that's nearly a gun for every man woman
and child and business is booming gun
sales have soared over the past decade
and lately major advances in security
technology have led to a convergence
with guns
most of ppk/s 9-millimeter short as in
microdermal sent through the grip in
code it'll pump into any you confided
gun technology is quickly advancing
beyond Hollywood and as both public and
political support surges the era of the
smart gun may have arrived we're going
to boost gun safety technology if we can
set it up so you can't unlock your phone
unless you've got the right fingerprint
why can't we do the same thing for our
gun
Kies fingerprint enabled handgun
represents one-of-a-kind smart gun
technology and development another is
rfid championed by jonathan Mossberg the
Mossberg family runs one of the
country's largest shotgun companies
jonathan branched off to focus on rfid
smart guns there's a chip inside the
ring it's oh yeah sure enough now that's
16 year old technology the new
technologies about size of a grain of
rice may be even smaller but the idea is
like if I wear this then I'm the only
one that can operate this gun rights
programs
yeah without that you have that you
can't fire the gun if you take the ring
Knight now you know and I was trying to
tick the safety off him
and went to go fire nothing nothing yep
I'll put the safety on just we're
galleys yep rings on yep firm grip and
you'll hear click we're there soft click
safety off and bring rip yep
pretty cool huh yeah what was amazing is
it just doesn't work each other work
yeah a survey conducted last year by
Johns Hopkins found more than half of
Americans would consider buying a smart
gun but despite this demand major gun
manufacturers still aren't developing
the technology why is it taking somebody
like yourself sitting here in their dorm
room designing the gun hey you know it
wouldn't this be something that they
would love and want to be a part of and
a lot of ways the firearm industry is
content you know they're growing every
year they're selling more and more guns
and they're able to more or less you
know resell the same technology over and
over again
if we were trying to introduce a new app
there's a very like everywhere expected
new app those hundreds a day right but
with a new gun there hasn't really been
one in the last 100 years one example is
the popular 1911 style handgun which has
changed little since it was adopted by
the military in the year 1911 but
industry resistance is deeper than
research costs the caustic battle over
gun control has made smart guns a highly
divisive topic there's a law still in
the books in New Jersey comets in the
process of being repealed that basically
mandates smart guns in the state once
the smart gun is sold anywhere in the
United States how do you feel about it
it's a horrible law it's completely
destroyed the market for twenty years
and honestly like we sort of as a
company in a lot of ways are counting on
that logging repealed it was this woman
New Jersey State Senator Loretta
Weinberg who pens a bill intending to
help bring the technology to consumers I
used to say to people about marriage
equality if you don't believe in gay
marriage don't marry a gay you know if
you don't believe these guns are going
to work don't buy one as simple as that
the bill was designed so that if a
single smart gun was sold anywhere in
the US the law would required New Jersey
gun stores to only sell smart guns
within three years so the bill was
interpreted as gun control yes that
would be chipping away at the second
Emmett right correct gun rights
activists
were determined to prevent any smart gun
from being sold anywhere in the US twice
however it almost happened
a German smart gun company called ARMA
tix tried to get their gun into stores
but in each case the owners faced a
tidal wave of violent threats from
across the country one owner in Maryland
faced so much pressure he barricaded
himself inside his store he was sitting
in his gun store all night long making
this YouTube because he was afraid that
the Second Amendment people were going
to come and burn down his store
obviously I received numerous death
threats today I really appreciate that
instead classy it's a great thing for
gun rights when you threaten to shoot
someone how can the NRA or people want
for hibbett of gun when we're supposed
to be procon the Marquis Greg the more
verbal he became go with it that's the
people who call up and threaten the
children we ever sold an armed desk
instance the controversial ARMA tick's
pistol is this one the IP one a 22
caliber handgun that only fires if the
shooter is wearing a special watch okay
so if it was in this hand thread yep
then here it's Cranford Asha fire yep
after the backlash armor kicks realized
it needed a new plan for the u.s. they
hired this man Wolfgang terrorist to
oversee the new strategy by upgrading to
a bigger gun a new 9-millimeter why is
it such a big deal to come out with a
9-millimeter 22 is a little small
colorful for the United States
everybody goes 9-millimeter 45:38
because of peda in other words to be
taken seriously in the u.s. you have to
be dealing with a 9-millimeter 22
caliber ain't gonna do it
oh really yes Wow well you know a lot
about our market this new 9-millimeter
has never been seen by the public
but after promising to keep our footages
secret until a certain date
Harmonix agreed to show it look and we
headed to their lab in Munich to see the
protocol so this is the this is the new
nine millimeter you have influences some
context to new entries to authenticate
just like somebody typing a code to
unlock their iPhone yeah this is the
same thing except you're doing it with
your fingers on the handle of the gun
once you have to trade a little bit okay
they just handed me the gun to see if I
can unlock it now it's locked
to unlock now it's online even if ARMA
kicks can prove their new gun is
reliable selling that concept of
Americans will still prove a huge task
instead they plan to put their gun in
the hands of law enforcement first so we
headed back to the state live with the
largest police force in the country the
NYPD here at the firearms training
center in the Bronx officers fire
thousands of rounds with serviced guns
that have undergone rigorous testing to
pass approval by the force when we asked
the street cop about adopting smart gun
technology the idea was immediately met
with skepticism or tapping the bottom of
the magazine make sure it's seated we
rack the slide and that should fix that
problem if I'm to add some sort of an
electrical opponent to this mechanical
device I don't have a fix for that right
because that's a computer issue rightly
how do you feel about the idea of
carrying a smart gun as a police officer
you have a gun to protect yourself and
more importantly to protect the public I
can't defend people's lives with a tool
that I don't feel comfortable with I
need that reliability a lot of people
see the police force adaptation of this
technology being the way forward as a
way of keeping other Americans safe
that's a pretty scary thought to think
about is that one you would want to use
law enforcement as a marketing
tool these aren't people that you kind
of want to use as a guinea pig these are
people that are stepping up and agreeing
to protect themselves put themselves in
dangerous positions and pretend to
protect your family I've NYPD
headquarters in Manhattan top brass
echoed the same concerns about the
reliability
despite some pressure from politicians
and the public to adopt smart guns so
would you say it's important to the NYPD
to explore smart gun technology yeah
we've been exploring it along with law
enforcement generally in the country
what we worry about is reliability
durability if it's going to meet that
rigorous standard it's something that
departments might want to look at at
least in a pilot program capacity that
technology has to be a hundred percent
reliable for an also to have confidence
in that is that going to be compromised
to blunt flaws battery drainage and
there's a host of issues there as law
enforcement does move forward with
testing out smart guns it would be a
major step for supporters but for many
this strategy simply delays adoption by
the public where they say the real
crisis is what inspires you to make a
smart gun for me it started as a
combination of a couple different things
this was right after the Aurora theater
shooting and so I was looking for
science fair project and there's a lot
of reasons why we need change in the gun
industry namely the fact that we have
30,000 deaths from firearms every year
the United States and the 21,000 firearm
suicides eight hundred children who die
from firearms every year a 2013 report
by the Centers for Disease Control found
that five hundred people were killed
that year by accidental discharge David
Hemingway professor of health policy at
Harvard the leading expert on death and
injuries by firearms it's so incredibly
dangerous for the family to have the
handgun around in terms of suicide and
accidents and spousal abuse and so forth
one point six nine million households in
the United States right now where
there's children and an unsecured
firearm and the research shows you put a
kid in the room with them a lot gun if
they find it they're going to play with
it but sometimes you play some quick
draw with his best friends or younger
they're in the blood here and bang from
is that for two to four year-olds it
turns out this is the one age group two
toddlers who shoot themselves they find
the gun and they pointed at themselves
and when their funds are just strong
enough to pull the trigger how did we
solve the problem about aspirin bottles
little kids used to overdose on aspirin
we made it childproof aspirin bottles we
can do that with gun accidental
shootings account for far more deaths
per year than school shootings but that
number is dwarfed by suicide
twice as many as total homicide and why
is a gun such an effective method for
suicide is so easy to use and it's so
easy to kill yourself a gun and home
increases the likelihood that someone in
that home will die of a suicide
substantially maybe threefold as they
take 100 pills they have a two percent
likelihood of dying if they shoot
themselves in the head they have a 90
percent chance of dying with numbers
like these it's easy to understand why
smart gun advocates feel such urgency to
bring this new technology to market but
the greatest hurdle to do so they lie in
the country's bitter divide over gun
control I will not be bored of anyone or
anyone when it comes to gun four years
ago I got two responses one was timeless
parka and - oh my god those things are
horrible that's a lot different than we
see today you know there's a lot more
people who know less mark then is and in
lockstep with the NRA the gun industry
won't consider developing smart guns
until the public demands them the gun
manufacturers themselves are making
enormous profits are one of the few
industries they don't want to make their
products safer well when they think
about cars we want them to think about
sex and power and we don't want them to
think about this is a very dangerous
product that they can get seriously
injured
and I think the same way with with guns
you want to think about oh you can
imagine all these incredibly heroic
things you did and you don't want to
think about the dangers you were
bringing into your home everybody knows
about the NRA and all that but the real
underbelly of it is very much under the
radar screen the people who are funding
it and the people have sold their souls
for it our full documentary series
covers such issues as the rise of
assault weapons concealed carry permits
and guns on campus make sure to watch
our entire series and subscribe to aj+
to watch more docs